[Music]
are you going
anything yes since it looking back at
the videos from it's all really where
should your eyes
it seems like most the time they're not
even looking at the person it's just
yeah you know in that book that we were
we we have had as our required reading
he gives you the traditional Chinese
which is the traditional martial arts
you know conventions for once the best
time to to go to your master right and
yeah that made total sense to me I I
have conveyed to you several times that
many of my masters were you know the
more sophisticated their art was the
Devore it was beyond my comprehension
they seemed crazy right and I have
talked to you a lot where yeah I can
feel that I could feel that you know I I
tend to just think of that kind of
Mahayana Bodhisattva concept is somebody
who hangs out long enough to help other
people but at a certain point you're
hanging out is just is limiting you and
so what the conventional wisdom is is
that you at a certain point your master
is done teaching and they're there now
on to their own studies and and you you
can't they got nothing to show
that you could grasp so and so I think
that's one of those things that you've
seen in me
when you know my eyes are going by the
i-10 I tend to look up a lot like
because I when I when I feel the art
it's more like something inside of
something inside of me it's it's more of
a feeling the very much like when I when
I when I try to teach you guys in the
marksmanship to to reach that kind of
robot feeling and you just in that zone
like that mind is the same mind of zazen
but mine doesn't explain it for us
Westerners because mine for us is brain
it's a feeling I feel it's somewhere
around here you know so what do you what
do you chest diaphragm torso area right
I tend to feel it like right there and
it has this kind of expanding expansion
like sense to it and so my eyes kind of
are starting to follow to follow it and
it's not it's not necessarily
what you guys should be doing so you got
to watch what's happening in light of
those Chinese conventions but beginner
wise right your eyes should be on your
partner
that mind
that the position in the placing of your
eyes on your partner generally in a
place where you can see head-to-toe is
going to stop your monkey minding do you
get it so you can control the mind by
aiming the eyes so to speak especially
for short durations of the one to two
seconds of technique and Jean Chien at
the end so you use it like that but
again that's a beginner technique so the
beginner what did I just tell you why do
you have to do that to calm the guy to
get the monkey mind under control
so you'll kind of think of it like you
know taco Han talks about this so the
Zen monk 17th centuries in monk and he
talks about there's people who will do
their Buddhism and they talk about you
know you have your mind is like a wild
cat or a wild monkey and you're going to
tether it so you tie it to a stake and
now it can't go anywhere and you can't
get it into trouble doesn't eat your
food doesn't [\h__\h] on your bed right and
he's off yeah it kind of works but
wouldn't you rather have a trained
monkey right who won't eat your food and
doesn't [\h__\h] in your bed so he he draws
that analysis that that that's a
beginner mind training advanced mind
training doesn't have oh doesn't have
that while
right not jumping all over from thing to
thing so that's kind of what you're
you're seen and we're not my mind is
just I don't have you I don't you're not
my opponent it's for my my self
perception of correct application is
that feeling like you can
biomechanically identify it but it will
always feels wrong to me if I don't have
that feeling just like I've had some
shots like I've taken a shot and I could
tell I didn't have that feeling and I
broke the shot and I go you're gonna
miss because I didn't have the feeling
hit right in the bullseye right I don't
go
I guess that feeling is not important I
go lucky [\h__\h] that that's how it
is to me so I'm more interested in that
dead feeling of all the years of reps
and training and practice has developed
a particular feeling that's telling me
this is the proper organization timing
right and so where do I look to see that
do you do you understand I can't it's
not a database so it doesn't it make
sense that I'm looking everywhere
simultaneously yeah
make sense it's not all that different
really from focusing on your okay at the
beginner level right so at the beginner
level we're if you remember when we
teach the back break balls we have you
focus on the wall and the wall is your
point of reference and as you get as you
get higher up you are now focusing on
your okay and then as you get higher up
your gaze is not important your case is
not important it won't pull your head
and compromise your posture like it will
in a beginner and at that point then
that feeling is probably the most
important so I the reason I mentioned
those Chinese conventions is I was very
aware of my teachers you know being on
the fringe of
[Music]
you know on my my culture because my my
wife didn't really train and I could
watch her freak the eff out by these
crazy people right and then and and I'm
enough have enough awareness or I can
tell like it's very easy now nowadays to
do to go this is all [\h__\h]
and every a lot of stuff feels very real
to you right not so much to other people
kind of train this this way so we we
talked about that earlier one the people
that I have found who have been self
reflective without a kind of organized
training they seem to have suffered a
huge amount but then I've seen other
people that have suffered a huge amount
and they didn't make it through itself
even that can't be that accurate but
I've never seen somebody without the
training who's self reflective but for
they suffered a lot in life if you knew
their life you would go holy cow and
what do you have what do you see with
them they have they aren't able to see a
lot of the [\h__\h] so somebody who's
ice to have a friend in college oh he's
a little he's a he was actually my
student at that time dear dear friend
and I met him in college super funny
super smart handsome beyond belief he
look like a total model and he wanted to
do train with me and we just beat the
crap out of each other back then I
wasn't I didn't do any of the stuff that
we do now to address learning curves it
was like I got 12 I only teach 12 people
and we're gonna just beat each other we
didn't have class times like like we
started I think it was 4 but there was
no telling when it was gonna end and it
was just pound on each other he's out
there broking this broken that and you
know you get to know each other and then
I found out he was homeless as a boy he
was homeless and his his hate and his
mom used to eat out of dumpsters and you
just would never know
[Music]
and did nowadays he's like total
contract lawyer huge firm in San
Francisco super well-off
[Music]
he brought his wife here one time huge I
don't know if any of you remember he him
and his wife came his wife started
crying when she saw this the whole thing
I think she could tell where he thought
a lot of who he is
you know and stuff but he suffered a lot
and he always had that he he we could
sit there all day long
midnight 2 a.m. from a class
and go on like that
so I think at this level I near CEMP I
should probably tell you you know hey
that's what that's what sensei's doing
but you should do this right I try to
still do that I try as much as possible
but if you give me a couple reps like go
into myself so stick to the basics okay
that could go for even like when I'm
asking to get soft I'm asking your
technique to have more disappearing I'm
not asking your technique to disinfect
you see that I think it's been quite a
mistake that people watch these old man
tapes of both sensei and then they try
to copy you know old man or sensei only
they didn't do the 40 50 years of
pulling tree trunks out of the ground
training right
you know I think if you're really
sincere about the path you would do what
they did right you wouldn't just jump to
the end so and I think that's where the
conventional wisdom of those of the
Chinese martial arts comes from me
yeah don't catch don't catch that master
of that because you're not gonna [\h__\h]
yeah don't be mislead you gotta catch
him right would they say like in the 50s
I think it is whoo I'm right right
because they start playing they start
playing like my teacher and I start
playing with stuff you know I literally
had to go I had to go man I'll get to
that later right it's interesting but
that's the problem is it becomes
intellectually stimulating and that's
not the training you start playing you
start making these riddles out of these
things like how did that punch get that
powerful and now you're just doing a
freaking cultivation drill you're not
you're not fighting do you get it that's
what happens all the time
so
stick to the stick to your basics I try
to do as much thank you try to do that
too
so like a 5 or 5 or euros I I was your
senpai and I see you start you know
looking up to the [\h__\h] great beyond
oh hey put your chin down you're gonna
get a knock the [\h__\h] off as a set Potter
right never will says they did that's
[\h__\h] sensei right you do you keep
your [\h__\h] chin down
right that's what that's what I would
say
it's not doing anything for my posture I
know
regarding the book I know you say that
sometimes you might recommend something
bridge is based on one good paragraph
there's one good part yeah and as I've
been going through it there been some
things where it's like that doesn't seem
like what sensei does there other parts
that leap out like yeah okay I've heard
that yeah I'm curious what what in this
book because I don't want mistake for -
what what didn't this book stands out
well this is one of those things where I
tell you not I don't want you to follow
me at the end I want you to go through
the journey so my journey was twelve
years of you know academic study at some
of the highest level in the world for
this kind of thinking
you can't just if you just repeat what I
said that's not at all what I teach so
you have to read these books so I look
for books that aren't too expensive that
aren't too long that do surveys and
summarize without being so general that
they're just wrong okay
and it's not that it's that this book is
wrong but it's not the end all it's just
part of your journey so I guess what I
would take from this book and I think
you should do this every time if you are
a deshi with a mentor is you know what
is different because what is different
is your teacher consciously chose not to
do that if you can't if you if you don't
have in your mind that your teacher is
capable of consciously choosing
something in that if they just through
their own institutional inertia so you
know ended up where they ended up man
don't that's not a mentor that leave
that [\h__\h] I can tell you every reason
why I don't do what they do
so a couple things I think in that book
is you have a very good description of
yin young philosophy it's very good in
that book is it kind of you know I don't
I don't have 12 years to do a doctorate
degree in this I just give it to me and
it's a good place um I also think it's
important to show it's a good book on
showing how deeply you can take this
where everything is correlated every
aspect from you know we kind of just
stick to these very large categories of
you know fitness sleep management world
view that that kind of stuff but now man
right how do you what haircut do you
have and when what do you what should
you smell when you're men straightening
it you know it's like it goes on and on
that's how that is the culture out of
which the idea of the martial arts as
the technology of self arose okay so if
that's the case then then how far are we
away from that when our martial arts
training is like fitness or socializing
or or even self-defense
it really makes no sense to think of
this like that and there's no it's a
historical warping when the arts have
become that and it's a mixture of just
really not a me it's just ignorant
people don't know they don't know
there's when you when you join a normal
dojo they don't they don't resign
reading right you don't get doubt are
you kidding me
you're lucky if they show up yeah you
want me to read you want me to read
outside [\h__\h] dot I got a school right I
don't know if you've paid attention
somewhere in between the books that I
require reading there's about five more
recommended reading those are just the
ones I'm recommending right if you are
smart you go get wha how many is he
actually reading okay so what where
should you be
so that that book kind of tells you Wow
holy cow
everything everything
it's those lists are just insane right
the herbal combination of the
the time of the hours of the day the
seasons everything
I then the next thing is well then why
aren't why don't you do it I think that
it's kind of like how I said when you
come to those masters that are working
at their own level that is so hard to
digest that they become intellectual
curiosities and so you start to focus in
on that as a riddle and you pay
attention you overemphasize the drills
such that you start working on
projection okay so you're gonna work on
Fauji you're gonna work on your
projection you have all these projection
drills you don't know the [\h__\h] first
thing about fighting somewhere in your
head you thought that guy was gonna come
in and you were gonna project him out
right
only he throws a jab right she jab right
cross left hook boom
you're knocked out and you ain't
projecting [\h__\h] you get it so because it
was just a drill it was not the fighting
so in the same way when you have all of
these governances of like two hours and
the diet and everything like that that's
how I understand them what are they
really trying to do
well you have had several answers to
that but I think they in in the Taoist
tradition they really come down to two
and one is and it's mentioned in the
book is physical immortality
and then the other one is this kind of
sage holy holy man not at all that
different from the saint or the Buddha
so I looked at those two and I said like
[\h__\h] really I want to [\h__\h] live
forever really is that really the height
of my [\h__\h] existence I don't know I
think you gotta be a real idiot to to
want to live for forever that assistant
US vice I I ran through it I ran you
know I ran through this philosophical
argument wait let me get this straight
so all this suffering and [\h__\h] and
the [\h__\h] crap forever that doesn't
make sense to me
or I could do this other thing
where I'm not subject to it and I'm not
someone who passes it from me to another
person to me that that person even if
you can do it for a moment is better
than someone who lives for forever and
can never do it so that's why I just and
that is really in there that is really a
part without was in the Chinese are
but to me it wasn't it's just not
important so I you know I might come
across this dude and he might go you
need to drink this tea and stir in this
direction and circumnavigate this thing
in it and I could man you're a [\h__\h]
[\h__\h]
doing it
but if I do all that I'm just like you I
know I don't want so that's why we don't
do it but I like that point that man it
does show you can't be exercise
socialization or self-defense that kid
can't be that you just can't do that
that is not the way that's not a way
that's a hobby
hobbies don't do anything for us there's
no technology of the self in a hobby
right we're never gonna break out the
Riddell aircraft carriers don't smell
the glue to recap it it's time to do
anything for you your fears are not
being ready to sell them they're not
being brought to the surface what's the
worst thing damn I glued the wrong piece
the glue dry it's not it's not gonna do
it so what we what we end up doing is is
geared more towards the sage life so if
I'm interested for example in the
dietary prescriptions of any kind I'm
interested in and only in terms of these
other things
we have highlighted so like is it
allowing your fitness to be at a level
where you can train at a level where you
are practicing self-cultivation or are
you too weak are you too frail do you
have not enough muscle on your frame
it's one thing to do the art and did not
have use muscle but you're dreaming if
you're gonna train four to six hours a
day and you're gonna be you know mr.
veal you know feel no you can't do
anything like that so we're interested
in the diet that way we're interested in
the diet in the way that is this is this
making me more triggered is my nutrition
predisposing me towards anxiety and
depression do you see that that's we're
interested in that I'm not interested in
is this T going to give me ten more
years of life do you see that so we
we've kind of veered away and he he in
the book he tries to say that the
immortal side you know that they saw
[\h__\h] he's that part's not true the
the health and wellness in terms of
longevity is by far much more popular
than the sage like them this sage aspect
of Taoism is popular in philosophical
circles in first world countries who are
dying but as far as every all that
others there man you you can't go
anywhere without that stuff Howard how
Chinese were
I'm not sure that question very well
something but my parents to talk about a
lot of the health aspects that this book
also talks about yeah and when they
heard about low carb diet they were like
no no you can't do that yeah yeah it's
interesting
and then like how many times did you
have philosophical debates on the on the
louts no it's like that everything
everywhere yeah they're like I don't
need them I don't need I don't need to
[\h__\h] understand the daodejing I just
got it I can drink these teas and sleep
this way and sleep on that side and you
know not have sex on this day and you
might decide otherwise I'm just my path
I think that's a waste of time that's
not not a travesty to me it's not a
failure do you know I mean it's not a
failure I have to avoid to me the
failure is I'm alive and I'm an [\h__\h]
that's failure
so I will acknowledge there's some
chapters in there where I'm saying so I
guess if you're asked to be yeah don't
but you know I don't pay attention all
those chapters you might want to you
know maybe you have an ailment and
you've tried everything and hey try it
might work right just my aim is
different but I don't not really
denouncing it it's just not my my
orientation but if you know if you if
you're reading it and you deciding yeah
I I get what that that chapter hey skip
it go to the nice chapter right let the
next chapter speak to you if you want
don't don't hold yourself we've talked
about that before right don't I told you
I don't read the introductions anymore I
don't I don't remember who I don't
remember eyes the authors anymore it was
good thanks for academics
so just chapter one right now get
halfway through this book is total [\h__\h]
that's done because I used to go you
must finish don't don't have does not a
book report it's like this is the
biggest piece of boyish [\h__\h] put it away
okay so you you you are in kind of class
you've been required to read it but hey
you know I get it she
get to the next get to the next chapter
because in this book is divided up like
that so he's going to go through all the
different kinds of you know teas and
meditation then he'll do a hidden young
thing or a you know you get died yet I
know the book yeah audiobook when he
goes to that section where in the
paperback there is bought like pictures
and yeah and he's just like describing
the way the body moving in the audiobook
they did that yeah but it goes to show
you some that we have mentioned here how
these patterns the patterns of these
movements are ancient and that they
clearly had other other motivations and
reasonings reasoning behind them other
than this is what you do for a wristlock
do you get that and so one that I don't
think you should do away with is that
they oh by moving in the right way you
are developing the body for thou art
okay so let's just take what we might
want to call strengthen power right if
you don't follow the right curves I
don't think you generate the right kind
of stress on the body so that you then
don't generate the right kind of
adaptation okay so if you if you're
moving just your arms for example yeah
your deltoids and biceps might get some
strengthening to them but your
not going to develop that that overall
power that we want so when I see a lot
of Aikido
you know on videos from all around the
world that's what stands out to me holy
cow
you guys are frail mushy people right
and he mentions it in there when he
talks about this one master had a
student and the student kind of focused
in just on the philosophy and he noticed
the difference
this guy was mushy he has had rounded
shoulders right if you haven't gotten to
that part and I think you know what I
would take from that chapter is I
wouldn't necessarily go Kate what
movement is he do it and then try to
duplicate you can't learn that from a
book you need a master for that right
but I would take the idea that yeah
these are not free-for-alls
okay I can't just manipulate the wrists
any other way I want to there's
something else I'm working on that I
have to be doing so you know you still
have that you guys all have the question
before you is how can you find the power
that you're seeing
right because it first glance it doesn't
make it bad which is why a lot of people
dismiss it a lot of people will tell you
right it doesn't look like just throwing
you that hard
right like even on yesterday on those
videos if you just watch me I'm barely
moving but if you watch how you fall
right you need that sedition you gotta
go okay
that's not you can it's not a magic it's
not magic it's not the force right and
it's definitely not the art like like
you know what I mean like dude you just
you just agreed to start it's not
amazing [\h__\h] kick-ass yeah it's like
Aikido basis all power no it doesn't you
have to train a certain way to find a
certain kind of body cultivation and
then that gives you the power so yeah I
would take from that chapter it's not a
free-for-all
stop moving any old way you want stop
doing that
not not just in terms of architectural
viability just in terms of body
conditioning okay we were doing some
striking in the in the
kids class the kids advanced class right
and you can tell the difference when you
win that thing it we're barely barely
touching right but organized condition
body not not condition like you know
CrossFit but this kind of Budo East
Asian martial arts body conditioning
that that conditioning how do you get it
that's the riddle you have to figure out
and I think we would do ourselves a
disservice when we don't start with I
should just do these patterns the way
that they're taught to me maybe that's
it you know what I mean maybe that could
be it rather than I keep making up the
crap we lose things imagine if you did
yoga right how the postures are so
straight if you if you're if you're
training with a real yogi oh man well
first of all you don't do that reign
postures but if you did it's not a
free-for-all right I mean what what is
the conventional wisdom the hardest pose
corpse you're like you shoot me
oh just lie down now obviously that's
not it right otherwise that wouldn't be
the hardest pose right okay so how much
more so this ancient body wisdom that's
moving and that is dynamic
I gotta stop doing the free-for-all
stuff I'm missing out on things all
those things that he's listing that you
went ahead and skipped over it's fine
because you're not an academic if you
just do this but all those things he
listed yes that's all right there
totally